人間に自信つけちゃうんですね
自信つけちゃうと もう怖いものはなしと
平気で山を登ると そういうことなんです
ですから 我々仏教から言うのは
徹底的に自信つけちゃうと何の心配もなしと
お守りも必要でなくなると
でも世の中不浄・無常だからね
お金今あっても明日もうどうなるかわからない
そこで不満が生まれると
今健康ですけど 明日からもう病気になってしまうかわからないし
だから明日どうなるかわからないんだから
無常だから いつでも不満というのは生まれてきます
だからこのご利益狂っていうのはなかなか消えないんです
世の中から じゃああの
ちょっとだけ もう四時半で終わりますか？次で
五時 え？四時半 あと十分しかありません
やっとテキストに入るようになりました
[笑い]アビダンマだけになっちゃったら
もう勉強したくならないほど
ものすごいドライといえばもうこれほどドライな教えがないんです
ですから いくらかそういう風にまあ時間かけて役に立つようにしなくちゃいけない
それだから僕でもそれは一日二日で終わったんだから
その辺は 心のところは
私はたった授業一つで終わっちゃったんです
覚えて丸暗記して分析も全部そこまで終わっちゃったんだから
まあ一時間の授業で それだけやるならば
でもそれぐらいの基本的な訓練ないとね
もう意味がないし 僕らにとってはパーリ語っていうのはもう直接わかるし
問題なかったんだけどね
で この色界の心が十五種類あります
その十五は三つに分けます
一つは先心です と言うんですか
ん？え？先心 色界の先心五つと
意熟心五つと 唯作心五つですね
クサラ・チッタ ヴィパーカ・チッタ
キリア・チッタ 先心 意熟心
唯作心 ここでまとめた方が後ですごくやりやすいんです
十五種類あります でも名前は同じです
ですから 五つ名前だけを覚えれば
これから簡単です 善業を作ると生まれる心には先心と言うんです
善業の心で梵天に生まれ変われる場合は意熟心と言うんです
阿羅漢になった阿羅漢たちが善業を作っちゃったら唯作心と言うんです
ですから心は同じ じゃあ一番目の心はこういう風に書くんです
すごく長いんです ヴィタッカ・ヴィチャーラ・ピーティ・スッカ・サハガタ
その一行だけ覚えておけば
五つも勉強できるんです
ヴィタッカ・ヴィチャーラ・ピーティ・スッカ・サハガタ・パタマッジャーナ・チッタ
ああ 長くて嫌だなと思う必要ないんです
それだけ覚えておけば
もう全部できるようになるんです
ヴィタッカ・ヴィチャーラ・ピーティ・スッカ・サハガタ・パタマッジャーナ・チッタ
あ サハガタじゃない ヴィタッカ
大変間違えました 大きな間違い
こちらにエーカグタっていう言葉が入るんです
僕の頭に他の 経典に出てきた文章を思い浮かべたんだから間違えた
ヴィタッカ・ヴィチャーラ・ティーヒ・スッカ・エカッガタ・サハガタンなんで
そこにサハガタンが入っちゃいますけどね
こちらではテキストによって言葉変わりますけど
サヒタンですね 一応全くテキスト通りでないかもしれませんだけど
一応勉強しやすくようにこういう風に伝えましょう
で これはこの第一禅定の心なんです
ここで一般の心と何が違うかっていうことを書いてるんです
番目に出てくるのはヴィタッカなんですね
ヴィタッカっていうのは大体この考えるということと似ているんです
考えるという意味なんですね
ヴィタッカっていうのは
まあ一応とりあえず考えることと似ている意味だと覚えてください
ヴィチャーラっていうのはもう考える
観察みたいなものです
違うかな どっちか分かりませんだけど
なかなか説明はもう注釈書でもあんまり良くないんです
偉大なブッダ教長老の注釈もあんまり良くないんですね
僕個人の意見を言うならば
ですから説明難しいんだけど
ヴィタッカはなんとなく考えてるような感じで
ヴィチャーラは考えるってことじゃなくて
なんとなく見ていて観察している
言葉なしに観察しているような感じです
その二つは一つになって合わせてみると
一般的に言えば考えることなんです
そのヴィタッカ・ヴィチャーラは我々にもいつでもあるんです
これは用語ではジンとシー
ジンとシーと この漢字はテキストから見てください
難しい漢字でしょう ジンとシーと言うんですね
我々にはごく普通にある二つなんです
一般的にもあるんです
ヴィタッカ・ヴィチャーラが
どういうことかというと
このこの我々は何か見る場合は
対象を見る聞く場合は
そのものにそれを掴まって
それに乗っていなきゃ見えたり消えたりしない
聞こえたりしないんです
自分の意志でそこら辺にちょっと持っていかないと
大体何か考えちゃうと
その対象なかなか心から離れませんでしょ
頭の中で何か考えたりすると
何か妄想したりすると
その出来事はなかなか逃げていかないんです
忘れられないんですね
それは考えるんだからなんです
ヴィパッサナーの用語で言えば妄想しているんだからなんです
この妄想もヴィタッカ・ヴィチャーラなんですね
ジンとシー 一応それほどそれ以上は理解できるように説明はちょっと
もっと禅定として言うなれば
思考は残ってるんです
第一禅定に入っても思考のレベルは残ってるんです
ヴィタッカ・ヴィチャーラある場合は言葉は使える
というようなものなんです
思考が働いています 思考が働いて
その対象から離れないようにします
我々の経験で考えます
我々も何か人に何とかあったら
その瞬間にそれ終わるでしょうに
でも 1年  2年でもまだ残ってるでしょ
心の中に で それについてすぐ妄想が生まれちゃうんです
その妄想によって過去にあった出来事は消えないようになっちゃうんです
本当は何か人にぶたれたっていうのも
その瞬間だけなんですね
でもそれ 10年でも恨みを持っていっちゃうでしょうし
それは妄想の働きなんです
すぐ思い出したりする
頭に浮かんだりする 浮かんでまた明確に観察する
ああいうわけでそうします
これはこういうことでこうしました
こうだからこうなったとかね
そういうのはヴィチャーラな観察なんですね
ヴィタッカを思い出すぐらいのことで
ですから この瞑想 禅定の場合でもそのレベルはあるんです
対象はもう自分で捕まって
それについて乗って思考を働かせている
だから離れません どうせ禅定を作るまではずっと強引に概念を念じなきゃ禅定生まれませんでしょう
だから私の説明は思い出してくれるとわかると思いますけど
ただちょっとスチルを見ただけで禅定が生まれるわけじゃないんだから
それは強引に念じて念じて念じて念じて
ヴィパッサナーから見れば妄想なんですけど
徹底的にその対象について妄想を働かさないと禅定が生まれませんし
ですからヴィタッカ・ヴィチャーラはあります
次にあるのはピーティ
ピーティというのは喜
喜びの喜 それはもう喜び
それは肉体的に感じる喜びなんです
肉体的にも心でもものすごく喜び感じるんです
いわゆる荒波が荒っぽくてわらっぽいなんです
次にあるのはスッカ スッカは楽
楽を感じちゃうんです
それは英語で言えばハピネスなんですね
ピーティは英語でこっちこのテキストは joyと書いてます
訳していて zest joy pleasurable
interest スッカは bliss bliss happiness
スッカはこの喜悦でもいいんです
ピーティはもっと荒っぽくて
荒っぽくじゃなくて 波がちょっと荒いというか
体でも心でもすごくもう喜びを感じる
喜びですから スッカは喜悦感
もうちょっと落ち着いていて
ハピネス感 ハッピーだなと
その両方を感じるんです
でもものすごい強力なんです
波の喜びじゃないんです
抜群の喜び感じたんです
で 次の言葉はエーカッガター
エーカッガターというのは集中力
統一性 こちらの用語では一貫性とか何とか書いてるんだと思います
一境性 境というのは対象
対象と一緒になっている
一つになっている 一体になっている
一体になるほど集中力
すごい集中力があります
それでパタマ・ジャーナ
パタマというのは first 第1
ジャーナというのは禅定
第1禅定のチッタは心
そこで 第1禅定ではその特色があります
思考があります それからものすごい徹底した喜びがあります
それからすごいハピネスですか
喜悦感が感じます それから一体感があります
それだけ それはお釈迦様は心理学者でしたから
心理学的にいろんな宗教の人々は何か体験したら
神々とかどんなに言うか
それは嘘かどうか分かりませんだけど
これだけはもう誰にでもあるものだと
ですから このキエスクキエスクとかよくどんな宗教でも出てきますよ
で 我々の国ではよく言われることがありまして
人々が自分が禅定は体験しているんだ
禅定に入っているんだという言っている人々がいるんです
いるんだけど そこで禅定を誤解やるんです
瞑想していて心はどんどん弱くなるんです
膨らみ縮み見るとそういう経験あるでしょ
なんか見えなくなっちゃうんですね
あれは心が弱くなったことなんです
疲れていてなんか見えなくなっちゃう
怠けなんです 怠けですけど
ちゃんと座ってるんだから
そこで何でももういい加減であれもサティできるし
こちらもサティできるし
まあなんとなくいいやという感じになっちゃうんです
そこで自分がなんか心止まったような感じがするんです
あれは寝ているんです
心がこの有分身という心がありまして
そこに戻るんです 必要な興味ある対象がなくなったら心は寝るんです
いつでもそういうことなんです
すごい興味あると眠気がないんです
興味が消えていっちゃうと
つまらなくなってくると寝ちゃう
欲の人が寝ると体がだるいんです
また眠った後でも気持ちは悪いんですね
体がだるくていい気持ちじゃないんです
瞑想していて心落ち着いてるんだから
そのまま眠りに入ったら本人は気が付かないんです
そこで目が覚める 覚めたら
あれ 今自分にどうなったんですかと
わからないんです 別に体がだるいわけでもないんです
そこでまた膨らむ縮みを続けてしまっちゃうんです
そこで本人が禅定に入ったんだという誤解はする
禅定に入ったならば その時はきちんと何があったかと知っているはずなんです
すごく喜びを感じているはずなんです
もしかするとヴィパッサナーも辞めたいほど執着するほどのすっごい喜悦感を感じるはずなんです
ですから 眠気は全く消えている状態なんです
よくそういう誤解は出てきます
たまにいるんですよ 瞑想に慣れちゃって慣れちゃって
瞑想に入って 1時間  2時間
3時間 ずっと体を動かさないでずっといるんですね
で 禅定に入ってるんだと人に聞いたら
自分を自分を威張ったりはするんですね
でも知ってる人にはこの細胞を見たっても
この地水火風は常に変化しているんだから
瞬間瞬間 この深い眠りに入ったら
どんな地水火風が生まれるかと体自体変わりますからね
一般の人にわからないんです
それは寝ているんだとわかるんです
[背景音楽]禅定はそんなこの小さなちっぽけな経験じゃないんです
大胆な経験 そういうことで
あの誤解しないようにしてください
それだけ であの まあ瞑想やってる国々ではよくあるケースなんです
禅定だ禅定だと禅定体験してるんだとみんなに大げさに言いながら
まあ人を見たら全然成長しているようには見えませんね
なぜならば第一禅定に入っちゃったら
この五蓋ですか 五蓋は消えるんです
その五蓋は今日忘れましたけどね
まあちょっと次回は五蓋の話もちょっと説明します
じゃあありがとうございます
[咳]